K-pop.
It's an undeniable global force of nature.
Those synchronized dance moves, those flashy outfits...
...and songs like this.
The music gets fans all over the world on their feet and dancing.
K-pop is so popular for a couple of reasons.
One of them is it continues a long tradition of basically teen pop.
Britney Spears, the Backstreet Boys...
... even the Bay City Rollers and people like that from the 70s.
Something that they have done differently is the engagement with the fans...
...and the outreach to the fans.
The groups build fandoms and many of these fans...
...embrace and celebrate a different culture and language.
If a young fan starts learning how to speak Korean because of BTS...
...or trying to figure out what some of their lyrics mean or whatever,...
...that makes them feel that much more invested in them.
Forging friendships in the process.
The community they feel with fellow fans, camping out with them,...
...bonding with them, leads to other friendships...
...and most of them said "I've made so many friends because of BTS"...
...and what more can you ask for than that?